canada house in london on the 7th of
january last year and no
hint of what was coming 24 hours later
and a year ago today
harry and megan announced they wanted
out
in 12 months they've moved from the uk
to canada to california
and within the restrictions of covid
embarked on their new working
and family life but talk to experts on
american tax
and immigration law and a couple still
have hurdles to overcome
david lesperance advises wealthy
individuals including some
in silicon valley it'll be very
interesting to as they start to kind of
implement and executes part of these
projects to see
what the deal is and of course as i am
for a lot of my
clients particularly those in silicon
valley uh we are watching what
california is going to do with their
wealth tax proposal
deals with the likes of netflix and
spotify have proved they are
a couple with global appeal and still
clear on what they want to achieve
together
as we all know it's been a year and we
really want to honor the compassion and
kindness the archwell foundation may be
in the early stages but from gender
equality to mental health
miscarriage to racism we've heard them
speak out
every four years we are told the same
thing that this
is the most important election of our
lifetime for some
too political too preachy earning them
criticism back here in the uk
pr expert nikid worked with megan before
she met harry
you know you look at celebrity in a big
way and you think you know
a celebrity will do their autobiography
they'll do their film deal
and it's basically that kind of
blueprint but they've done it in a year
you know
i believe for that authenticity you have
to earn your stripes so hopefully
they're going to be doing that before
they do
too much more the last time we saw them
with the family they didn't appear to be
leaving on the best of terms
and it's hard to know how much contact
there's been since then
one thing that we do know is that when
they left in march
last year the queen said there would be
a review in 12 months
about the new arrangements what is going
to be fascinating to see is whether or
not the results of those discussions
play out as publicly
as harry and megan's announcement did
this time last year
when they left they promised to uphold
the values of the queen
in everything they do a benchmark that
will always define how their work is
judged no longer working royals but
forever members of a family
with a reputation to protect rihanna
mills sky news